Now going back to our mani-core challenges we have
seen that the number of cores as it grows
makes the coherence traffic grow and we looked at
solutions to deal with that. We then looked at
the problem of the off-chip traffic also growing with
the number of cores. And we just saw that
a large shared but distributed last level cache can
help with this problem. The next problem we face
is that the coherence directory that we need is just way too large to fit
on-chip. Because we have a scalable on-chip network and no longer a
bus, we need directory coherence. But a
traditional directory has one entry for each
possible memory block. The memory can be
many gigabytes in size. That might require
even billions of directory entries and that won't fit
on chip. So how do we deal with that problem?